what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest updates in the
one piece story this chapter had some
insanely hyped devil fruit awakenings
among other big reveals and developments
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these one piece
videos i want to keep them coming chill
the pirate king with it and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is pirate king
energy and passing is orochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos that's just the
way it works and while you wait for the
next exciting chapter to drop feel free
to check out my huge and growing
one-piece playlist that includes videos
from all the yonko warlords admirals and
much more link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called the impermanence of
all things i just mentioned this in one
of my last chapter reviews discussing
how foolish it was to believe as hawkins
did that the current yonko system will
never change since before the yonko
there was a pirate king and before that
the rocks pirates and so on everything
is in flux the yonko are getting older
and will eventually have to make way for
the next generation it's just a matter
of when so interesting to see with the
title that oda is hammering in on this
message again and it's sure to be a hype
chapter of changes with a title like
that we start away from the battle with
apoo and drake talking and there are
also three giant numbers there to boot
and the fact that drake is even here
talking and not fighting means he's
probably more open to this talk than we
might have thought at first apou knows
that drake's a marine spy and says all
he cares about is if he wants to take
kaido down which of course drake would
like to do props to apu for still
laughing and seeming fine after
everything he's been through including
being cut down by zorro he's definitely
worthy of the supernova title yeah he's
not moral but pirates don't have to be
and the fact that he's talking about
backstabbing ianko here means he's more
strategic than hawkins was at least for
instance hawkins didn't have to fight
killer at all if he was just looking
after himself again we can't be sure
that he won't just backstab drake if
kaido ends up being fine but he's
definitely convincing when he's speaking
to drake saying no matter how this war
ends the winner isn't going to come out
unscathed they'll be easy pickings he
ambitiously suggests teaming up with
drake and swooping in and stealing
victory at the last moment he makes a
lot of sense when he says neither of
them have a horse in this race and thus
there's no point for them to go at it
and after the way queen treated up who
it's not surprising that he would turn
on that unappreciative crew as soon as
he got the chance obviously drake has
trouble trusting him but apu points out
trusting has nothing to do with it since
the arrangement will be mutually
beneficial for both of them adding that
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
and appu is right even if drake doesn't
want to team up with him as a member of
the marines it doesn't make sense for
him to risk fighting a poo in these
numbers to the end when they're not
getting in his way and kaido is
obviously the bigger catch depending on
what he chooses to do we'll learn more
about drake's character and sense of
principles for sure i really look
forward to seeing how apu's plans pan
out in no world do i see him swooping in
and getting full credit for defeating
kaido and the straw hats but if he teams
up with powerful enough allies like
blackbeard perhaps who knows either way
he's a slippery dude and seemingly has a
way out whatever happens if kaido wins
he could keep pretending to be on his
side if he loses and the marines come
he'll hopefully have an understanding
with undercover marine drake he
definitely makes for an interesting
antagonist at this point we then see
hamlet carrying komachiyo to safety down
the stairs while usopp and nami spot
kinemon's detached legs begging for help
this is an interesting throwback to punk
hazard to be sure and it's hilarious how
they first mistake the legs for a
torso-less yokai usop hugs the legs
which in and of itself looks hilarious
and tells the legs that are looking for
some allies that he's an ally although
of course legs don't have ears and can't
hear so kinemon is clearly alive but
usopp does comment on how much he's
bleeding and yeah it is fitting that
kinemon gets to see the kind of man momo
becomes since the legs can't hear nami
draws the crescent mark of the rebellion
on him with her fingers and he realizes
based on this that they are allies the
legs request help and usopp rushes over
on hamlet who just looks so funny as he
moves around we find out that kinemon is
searching for help for kiku kiku is
barely clinging to life and needs to be
saved asap so even kiku is still alive
but it's not that surprising since one
piece is infamous for not killing off
characters after it's implied that they
may have died not that it never happens
but it usually never happens then there
are more character survivals kinemon
overhears orochi calling out to kanjur
kinemon thought orochi is dead so he's
surprised and he thinks that orochi is
unaware of kundro's demise but insanely
kanjuro is still kicking this guy just
won't die oda decided to jam pack all
these still alive moments in one chapter
and i guess by doing so we won't have a
bunch of chapters with one person
popping up revealing they're still alive
this way he gets a lot of them out of
the way at once and we can focus on
other aspects over the upcoming chapters
so kanjuro is on the brink of death but
still not dead and don't for a second
assume that he'll stop causing trouble
just because he's on the brink of death
oh no orochi gets him to paint the
burning wrath of the kurozumi clan with
the last strength he has left he tells
kundro free their souls and free us in a
final blaze of glory so kundrov views it
as a kurozumi pact and creates the giant
fire creature called kazembo this keeps
the yokai aspect alive as kazimbo is a
type of yokai and it's very fitting if
you ask me because this type of yokai is
associated with monks who were still
attached to life on earth and were thus
considered failed buddhas they appeared
in the form of a mysterious fiery
apparition and as we know kundra was
very attached to the material world and
couldn't even let go of old grudges
deciding to hurt betray and even kill
people who viewed him as a friend
because of them the fire that represents
the vengeance of the kurozumi definitely
looks huge and burns people it touches
as well as its surroundings it can even
travel through walls like some kind of
ghost and you obviously can't shoot it
dead as some people try to do in the
meantime momo is still trying to create
the flame clouds and panicking it
doesn't help matters that now a new fire
is spreading everywhere and the castle
is being choked by flames brook just
tells robin to run from the flames
because there's no time to fight we get
some great shots reminding us of all the
forces in play including cp 0 the
samurai marco we also see a great half
page of luffy zorro and sanji's fight
side by side the straw hat monster trio
versus the beast pirates monster trio
and seeing that was definitely a treat
hard to believe we've come this far
already orochi says the kuzuki forces
and emperors will be undone by their own
hubris aka pride he's just laughing as
they fight knowing about the weapon
stockpiled in the basement and how the
fire will reach it soon and i said that
momo would succeed in his flame clouds
mission but there would have to be
another reason that yamato went to deal
with these stockpiled weapons anyways
and here is a possible reason even if
momo is a smashing success she'll have
to get rid of the weapons before the
flames spread there luckily being an
ice-based japanese wolf deity should
give her the best chance of stopping
slowing down a yokai fire orochi also
lied to kanjuro about the pact for them
to die with the rest of them because
he's waiting for fukurokuju so they can
escape together saying this pirate war
is no longer any of our business man it
will be so satisfying when this dude
gets his just desserts just saying and
it goes to show how op mythical zones
are even this week coward could survive
so many otherwise lethal attacks because
of his hydra like power i gotta say i
love seeing yamato's giant wolf form
running through the scene it would be so
useful and cool to have someone like
this around on the crew hashtag yamato
for straw hat she reaffirms to us that
momo will have to slow the island down
even if a bit so she can get to the
weapons at the bottom of the castle and
deal with them then we jump to the most
hyped part of the chapter big mom
fighting kid and law and using insane
attacks like ikoku sovereignty big mom's
really going at it and then we get a bit
of a flashback of kid and law talking
before this moment kid asks law if he
can awaken his ability and law says he's
not used to it yet he'd only use it if
they were near death since it burns too
much energy to use in real battle and
kid says his the same but they're not
getting anywhere without it and although
obviously there are drawbacks to using
the powers all i heard and got hyped
over was the fact that they both have
awakened abilities so they decide to
play their ace cards which are their
awakened devil crew powers that is so
hype not one but two awakened supernova
abilities targeted towards a yonko no
less oda is amazing at making multiple
amazing fights happen simultaneously
although i obviously am hyped to see
more of zorro vs king and luffy versus
kaido and so on i am totally okay and
enthralled with this king and law versus
big mom in the meantime law uses the
move croom which likely refers to
chromium which is poisonous in the body
and is lethal if the dose is high enough
he coats his sword with it and stabs
through big mop he says the incision is
harmless in and of itself although it
looks crazy just stabbing a yonko
through the neck but as he explains the
croom influences the body in other ways
he then unleashes a shock wave and big
mom starts bleeding from the mouth big
mom seems upset but relatively fine
afterwards now the question is will this
move have lasting damage and effects on
big mom's body as the name suggests it
should in theory weaken her and slow her
down and even get worse as time passes
but again i'm not sure how anime logic
will play itself out in this instance
anyways for now big mom is mad and
distracted by law so it's kids time to
show his awakening he uses a sign to
make big mom become a magnet all weapons
are being drawn to her and even the
steel beams of the tower are being
ripped out then kid tells law to get him
out of there and la uses his power to
make big mom and kids switch places thus
big mom is supposedly crushed by all the
falling debris as kid screams out punk
crash it's funny how again law was
saying don't tell me what to do before
he followed kids instructions despite
how cool a lot is he always seems to be
the one who loses it when luffy or kid
gives him orders but wow what a chapter
we're told by the narrator that this is
the awakened power mentioned and again
wow did it ever look awesome i find it
hard to believe that big mom is down for
the count but either way hopefully the
combination attack and especially lost
chrome attack will have lasting effects
and damage on big mom giving them an
upper hand keep in mind though they
probably won't last long either because
of the drained energy they spoke about
earlier so it's really a race to see who
drops first but if law and kit awaken
their fruit powers then we can
definitely expect fifth emperor luffy's
awakening too the question is has he
already awakened and that's why he's
able to do so well against kaido one on
one or are we on the brink of seeing
this awakening from luffy it would make
sense in a shonen story to save luffy's
awakening for after we see laws and kids
and not to mention it would be way more
hype if we saw something new so i do
have hopes that we will see something
new from luffy like with law and kid
though it will probably drain a lot of
stamina and will thus intensify the
final conflict but yeah let me know your
thoughts on all this the chapter once
again was called the impermanence of all
things and we saw big mom get wrecked
pretty hard at the very least the attack
reaffirmed that big mom is not
invincible does anybody think that she's
actually down for the count or at least
that she'll be considerably weakened
when she gets up will we see luffy's
awakening soon in epic fashion if the
supernova could pull it off the
so-called fifth emperor should be able
to do it too finally let me know what
you thought of this chapter and what you
expect to see in the next chapter mvp
for me will be shared by kid in law this
time around absolutely amazing to see
their awakened powers and whether
temporarily or not they made a yonko
bleed and then brought her down in epic
fashion let me know if you agree or have
another mvp in mind but anyways that is
it for this one another great chapter
with great moments as far as i'm
concerned if you did enjoy this chapter
review you know what to do channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is pirate king energy
and passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos that's just the way it
works and while you wait for the next
exciting chapter to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing one-piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko warlords admirals and much more
linked to that is in the description and
as i'm recording this there was
construction going on nearby and i
couldn't really do anything about it so
sorry about that but next week it should
be normal and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you